we're delighted to bring you the seminar
presented by labyrinths
welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation
titled cannabis medicine is flowering
how clinical trials
validate cannabis it's my pleasure to
introduce you to dr
deborah kimlis dr kimlis is the chief
medical officer for puregreen
she is also the medical director for
forward grow
and chief science officer for merida
capital partners
for a complete biography under speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions should arise during
this presentation we encourage you to
submit them into the q a box
our speaker will respond back to you via
email
and as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
please join me in welcoming dr kimlis i
will now turn the presentation over to
her
hi everyone my name is dr deb kimlis and
today
i'm going to speak to you about how
clinical trials validate
cannabis first i want to thank labruts
for giving me this opportunity to speak
today
and i want to thank the audience as well
for being interested enough to listen
so my disclosures i'm the chief medical
officer for pure green pharmaceuticals
a processing and
cannabis growing company in michigan i'm
the chief scientific officer marital
capital
partners and i'm the medical director
for fuller grow
cultivation company in maryland
so when i usually give talks and
webinars
my passion really is about educating
people
about the health benefits or the
medicinal
attributes of cannabis and
this is a new kind of um
a new kind of discussion when we furry
into conducting clinical trials
because there's really not a lot of
clinical trials being conducted
currently and we're going to talk about
one why it's important to even consider
doing a clinical trial using cannabis
medicine
two what are the issues regarding that
surrounding that
what are the challenges and we're going
to talk about some successes
but before we head into all of those
things the interesting thing about
cannabis
is that cannabis is a medicine is
is not new it's not a novel drug and in
fact
the earliest recorded use of cannabis as
medicine is in 2737 bc
where in ancient china the emperor
fancied himself a pharmacist and he
used cannabis to treat patients
suffering with gout
arthritis and absent-mindedness who are
alzheimer's
or dementia which i find incredibly
interesting
[Music]
in 1000 bc in india they used a drink
called bong
where they mixed cannabis with warm milk
and they actually used it as an
anesthetic
and the ancient egyptians used cannabis
for the treatment of tumors
and in 200 bc the ancient
greeks used cannabis topically
to treat their war horses after a battle
to help reduce inflammation and promote
healing
and then they recognized the successes
in their in their war horses
and started treating patients who
suffered with earache or edema or
swelling
inflammation and other veterinary
medicine issues
and from 1851 to 1941
cannabis was listed in the u.s
pharmacopoeia as in
actual medicine
this is what a label would look like if
you went to a pharmacy
back in that time where you could
actually purchase a cannabis tincture
it was interesting because my
grandfather actually practiced
in uh the late 1920s to
40s actually to 60s um as a pharmacist
and and he would have this is something
that he would have
um administered to patients so it's very
common
but i can't um describe how curious it
might be
or coincidental it might be that as the
prohibition
for alcohol stops the prohibition for
cannabis starts and there's a whole lot
of
uh social reasons for this vilification
of cannabis
flower and i'd like to send everybody to
martin lee's
incredible book called smoke signals
that actually sort of describes
all of the things as to why cannabis has
been vilified over time
but also around the same time
there was a push for getting rid of
snake oil
and looking at single molecules
to examine as a pharmaceutical and so
cannabis as a botanical is has over 400
molecules and therefore
seemed confusing as to which was the
active ingredient and not
and so therefore you know besides a
whole lot of other reasons
has been vilified and was taken off the
u.s pharmacopoeia
and so part of that is about people just
didn't understand
how this worked
however you know there was a time when
we actually didn't understand
digestion right i mean people didn't
parse that out including recently
where we're now just describing the
importance of the microbiome in our gi
tract
and how not only does it allow us to
onboard
macro micronutrients without an intact
microbiome
we probably would not be as healthy as
we are
and yet we're okay with continuing to
eat
clearly this was a pre-coronavirus
picture
yet even as early as the vilification of
of cannabis in the 1940s
really smart scientists were working on
figuring out
one the endocannabinoid system and two
all of the elements as to how our own
endogenous cannabinoids work within that
system
as well as how the cannabis plants
chemicals
work within our own endocannabinoid
system
these things um originally came out in
the
mid to late 1980s and to this day we're
still
learning more and more sort of like an
onion as you
peel it back we learn more and more
information about the endocannabinoid
system
and about the cannabinoid molecules and
how they interact within our biologic
system
however even though none of these things
have been completely characterized
people are still using cannabis for
all kinds of medical conditions
so much so that patients have seen
incredible successes with lots of things
including refractory epilepsy
people who have wasting with hiv aids
and therefore they
created advocacy groups that actually
pushed policy and legislation
to demand state rights even while
cannabis remains a federally illegal
drug
and so currently there are 33 states
and the district of columbia plus puerto
rico and guam
that have some sort of medical cannabis
program
and there are a bunch of different
constellation of conditions beyond that
refractory epilepsy and wasting syndrome
from
from hiv aids for which people are
using medical cannabis
and the challenge is is that policy
makers
and doctors and maybe patients feel that
this
cannabis stuff is a giant human
experiment and we need to understand and
characterize these molecules
and see the safety and understand the
efficacy
and that's the drive but the interesting
thing about cannabis
is not only its widespread ability to
interact with a whole bunch of other
biologic systems in our body
and effective change in a positive way
but their
safety profile is tremendous and thus
far
there are zero deaths from cannabis
so meanwhile we need to to answer these
people who believe that this is a great
blinded
[Music]
experiment and people always want to say
but we need
more proof so i did a pubmed search just
of keywords like medical marijuana
medical cannabis
cannabis marijuana marijuana effects
marijuana clinical trials cannabis
clinical trials
and without any effort i found
over 88 000 articles
written on the subject
yet many many people are still
screaming that they want to understand
where the clinical trials are
show me the proof and you know until
that happens
they're not going to believe that
cannabis
is medicine
so what does it take to do a study so
remember when we were in middle school
or high school
we had a science class and they said
okay in order to do a study you have to
come up with a hypothesis an idea
you know i believe cannabis is a
medicine and then you have to create an
experiment
okay we're gonna try you know a bunch of
people using cannabis and then you're
gonna follow the results and come up
with the conclusions
sadly our fda looks at this in a little
bit more
uh granular and it's not so easy
so first we have to define what is a
study
so people who look at case reports
things that i
share all over the country and all over
the world with patients that i see
and help guide using medical cannabis
styling
others call it anecdotal because
you know these are one-off cases of
patient patients who report using
cannabis for specific indication and
then have a specific result
and that probably is like the lowest uh
study so to speak on the on the totem
pole
the next is a cohort study where you can
observe a group of people
doing something similarly over time so
maybe there's
you know a group of children who have
refractor epilepsy
and they are all taking cbd that would
be considered
a cohort study and then a case control
study where you have two similar groups
and they differ only by a medical
condition
or treatment so maybe young healthy
women one has um
insomnia the others do not and then you
give
you know both groups cannabis what
happens
but the gold standard is something
called a double double-blind
randomized clinical trial
[Music]
although a single blind randomized
clinical trial is a reasonable choice
for
some as well but let's talk what is
what does it take to accomplish a
double-blind randomized trial so first
of all what is it
so the doctor or the health care
provider who's running the trial
and the patient the recipient of the
medicine
both do not know who's getting it so if
you have
a particular indication say diabetic
neuropathic pain
and you have a specific formulation of
of cannabis say you have a cbd
tincture the doctor doesn't know whether
the patient gets the cbd tincture or the
placebo
that's what it means by a double blind
and randomized means
that you have a group of patients that
are recruited to be
part of that study and they get
randomized
some get the placebo some get the get
the active drug
and neither the patient or the treat the
the head the um person in charge of the
of the um study do not know who's
getting it
but then it gets a little bit further is
this an fda trial
or a non-fda trial
so let's talk about an fda trial so
first of all why would anybody want to
do
an fda clinical trial well if a
medical cannabis company wants to be
able
to become fda approved
just like what gw pharma did with
epidiolex and then
a doctor can write a prescription
instead of a recommendation
and this these medicines can be sold in
traditional
pharmacies rather than cannabis
dispensaries
may be worth the while of the company
that wants to pursue this endeavor
so let's talk about what it takes to get
a drug through the fda process
so i have here on the slide slow
and slower and let's look at that
a little bit more specifically so when
you're looking at
slow 15 plus years this is a traditional
fda drug discovery development
and approval process this process is
long arduous and expensive
so the first part is first discovering
coming up with your hypothesis
i think this drug will work for this
specific indication
but before the fda will allow you to
even
try it in people we have to do
pre-clinical
testing pre-clinical testing means
testing in
a non-human
experiment or study most likely animals
that pre-clinical testing looks at a
whole host of things
not only did it work for this specific
indication
but was it safe what about the
toxicology was it toxic
what did it do over long term for organs
what did it do regarding um
future progeny if you know did it cause
dna disruption
and therefore um issues with
um further development of the animal and
or
uh if they have other animals then
then what happens with them it takes
about
six and a half years then the company
gets to file what's known as
an ind at the fda that's an
investigator's investigational new drug
and you bring all of this pre-clinical
testing
and any kind of information that's
already known about this drug
um journal articles to the fda
they come back with lots and lots of
questions
and meanwhile what you what they don't
tell you is that you just don't
present it via an email dear fda you
have to buy
specific uh software so that you have a
method
and that's secure to communicate with
the fda
this is incredibly expensive and arduous
to set up
if the fda says yes we grant you a an
ind
you now are allowed to do a phase one
trial phase one trial
is in normal humans generally where you
look at pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics
um and maybe you'll see some efficacy
studies there
again looking at the humans now clinical
trials as opposed to pre-clinical trials
to see that
this doesn't harm anyone that's
these steps alone take over
eight years to the tune of somewhere
between 50 and 840
million dollars
if you are alive to uh to to
move forward if you get some um data
that shows that this medicine
does no harm you're allowed them to go
to a phase two trial where you can
actually
look at um patients with a
disease-specific indication
and that takes about two years in phase
three trials where you get to broaden it
and look at
other secondary effects and see how
patients respond safety and efficacy as
well
and then those two processes cost
somewhere between
50 and 970 million dollars
and then you move forward you file your
ind at the fda
you get for about six months you go back
and forth with questions you answer
questions they
generally ask you to do things you may
have to go back and do more pre-clinical
testing depending upon what the results
are
the fda could remove um review
and approve it takes about one and a
half years
once approved you're allowed to sell the
product on an open market
and do phase four trials which is
basically just
you know doing observations and seeing
if there's anything that happens
this entire process at least 15 years
most likely more
and as you can see on the bottom of the
screen 2.6
billion dollars now let's
say okay well that's interesting but my
drug is cannabis
and you know it's kind of safe we've
been using it now for
a long period of time we just saw that
on the slide from 2737
bc and we know that it's safe and that
there's zero people
dying from cannabis so let's see what
the fda suggested research pathway is
for cannabis drug development
so first you have to decide whether or
not you want
more cannabis molecules coming from
botanical
from the flower itself or if you want to
have it
synthetically derived if you want it
botanically derived
there's two pathways you have to either
grow your cannabis
according to the fda's botanical
guidelines
but before you can do that you need to
have the ability to
cultivate and the dea is
has only thus far permitted one
cultivation
for federal cultivating of cannabis this
is at the university of mississippi
so you'd have to go through the rigors
of applying and getting
um products from the university of
mississippi which can take somewhere
between two to eight years if ever
and then submit all the cnc data
commensurate with all of all of those
things
um you can do a
[Music]
synthetically derived where the cannabis
molecules are made
in a beaker as opposed to in an actual
plant
again this is incredibly challenging
because you need to have a company that
creates these with a drug master file
that they filed with the deep
with the fda and is approved by them
and then you would need to again use
those companies drug master files and
cmc data
in order to have your starting material
or active pharmaceutical ingredient
also known as an api then you have to
obtain
investigators an investigator who
understands how to run
clinical trials someone that knows how
to do protocol writing
that understands the pathways between
non-clinical and clinical protocols
and all of the investigators because
there are different skill sets with each
the dea in order for you to even create
your novel medication
using either botanically derived or
synthetic molecules
you require a dea schedule like one
license
so the dna will refer all of your
protocols
to the fda in order to review so now
you're dealing with two federal agencies
not just one
all of this takes multiple multiple
years
and then if all of this is successful
you get to start at the fda
um clinical process or pre-clinical
clinical process in the slow column
so you've added at least three years to
traditional fda drug development
and so you can see how the slower column
melds into the slow column at the phase
one trial
or they may even with their new even if
with the drug master files they may
want you to run pre-clinical trials at
all
this is an incredibly difficult and
arduous task
that costs a lot of money so now let's
look at the non-fda trial so why would a
company why would a medical cannabis
company want to do a non-fda
trial well non-fda trials
are important to differentiate a company
if they so
choose to do so from all of the other
medical cannabis companies
because when patients go into dispensary
they're confused
and there's a lot of talk out there
because again there's
nobody is looking at these clinical
trials or
showcasing them for patients there's a
lot of
um iterations from a dosage of this
administration forms and a lot of
different uh
cannabis strains out there and it
becomes quite confusing
so a medical cannabis company may want
to differentiate themselves run clinical
trials for specific indications
and therefore can help sort of um
clear the path for patients to make at
least a starting choice
what's interesting is that there are
state mandates
for research so pennsylvania and
connecticut and west virginia
are leading the way actually carving out
special licenses for businesses who say
that they will
they commit to a research
um platform for their business
which i think is incredible and new
jersey is also exploring this option
so all businesses with legal cannabis
licenses
have an opportunity to do research and
so i did disclose that i
am the chief medical officer for pure
green and this is
what we're going to share with you this
is our non-fda trial pathway
where i get to think great thoughts and
formulate
cannabis based medicine in the form of a
sublocal tablet is what we're doing
we then come up with an indication for
which we think this tablet would work
we run proof of concept trials
we see how patients respond to it
we refine the formulation if needed
and then we actually conduct
phase two clinical trials using our
formulation for disease-specific
indications we get irb approval
we list our trial on clinicaltrials.gov
and then that helps promote sales
in michigan which is where we're located
where we're doing these
studies we also have a website a uh
a smartphone based app where we have
patients
um log in and utilize this app
as a method of communication and also
where we can do pharmacovigilance we can
see compliance
we can get feedback from patients we can
enhance the product
and then just continue to tweak our
formulation
all of this cost tens of thousands of
dollars
as opposed to millions or billions of
dollars
and all of this takes less than two
years
as opposed to greater than 15.
however it does cost money and there has
to be commitment from the medical
cannabis company
that is interested in conducting these
types of trials and
hiring the right types of people that do
this so i'm a
certified principal investigator we have
certified clinical research
associates that help write the protocols
do statistical analysis plans submit
documentation to irb
list uh trials on clinicaltrials.gov
involve ourselves intimately in
recruiting and it costs
a lot of money and it takes a lot of
time energy and effort
and so the difference between a cannabis
business versus a university related
business such as the ones that are
happening in pennsylvania
in west virginia and connecticut is that
generally speaking medical cannabis
companies
have no in-house resources
so they need someone that's going to
help them
[Music]
write the protocol
they have to hire
a statistician sorry crazy on my slides
um hire a statistician hire someone to
create the study documents
so it can be submitted to the irb the
irb is an investigational research board
that allows a third party to evaluate
the
ethics of whether or not this study
protects patients and make sure that
patients are safe and not harmed
and many irbs uh
are are not used to seeing cannabis
related medicines and so therefore they
have a lot of questions and
there's a whole host of documentation
that needs to go along with
that submission and you actually have to
hire somebody to
run the clinical trial and then you have
to have pharmacovigilance
and ensure patient compliance because
that's part of the study i mean
it's it's about safety for patients it's
about efficacy
for patients but it's also making sure
that patients are compliant and
and we get solid information
and then at the end we need someone to
collate data
submitted to a third party statistician
because statistics can be looked at in a
whole bunch of different ways
the statistician is blinded to the study
blinded to the patients and they
created a statistical analysis plan
initially
and then they will um enact that plan
when they get the data points
to see what those results are
and now this seems like an incredibly
difficult heft
to move this ball forward and to advance
the knowledge of
cannabis
but moving the needle on knowledge for
anything
but especially medical cannabis is
tremendous
and to be able to participate in that
has a true
tremendous um benefits
and that doctors and other health care
workers
will then understand
what it is that treat somebody with
medical cannabis
and then when you look at a therapeutic
order of operations
rather than going directly to
pharmaceutical maybe the initial safer
therapeutic option
could be a medical cannabis preparation
the other benefit would be legislators
and politicians who write rules and
regulations
could look at this and say we finally
understand
a stepwise approach that there's
specific diseases
specific indications and specific
formulations
and therefore maybe cannabis is scary
and they can change the rules
that not only will states be allowed to
have their programs but also it was no
longer federally illegal
which will allow patient access across
the country
as opposed to depending upon their
health care should not depend upon their
their zip code also
it would allow for normal business type
relationships including banking which
many cannabis
businesses don't have access to which
makes again running clinical trials very
difficult because they don't
have access to capital that will allow
them to
create these programs where they
normally maybe would have
and it would also serve as a a
great relief to patients who baseline
know that this cannabis medicine works
they still have this you know feeling of
stigma
regarding this because remember there
are lots of rules
that patients can't use medical cannabis
if they are participating in certain
activities one is they can have a gun
two is they um if they have a federal
job
and they lose their federal job there's
lots of things there's patients you know
moms who
may need it and they are fearful of
losing their children
so by legitimizing cannabis medicine
will allow for a whole host of benefits
oh another one is
children have to leave school property
to get their cannabis medicine
because school property if they go to a
public school is federally funded
and they're not allowed to take a
federally illegal drug
while on the school campus so that means
that
parents have to do their place of work
because they're
because they're the caregiver for these
children children have to be taken out
and they have to go and get ghost and
then go back in and that disrupts
you know parents work children schooling
the kids are separated out and look
different from everyone else and so all
of these things would go away
and so again normally i give
lectures on my over 400 patients that i
speak about
they are case reports i see tremendous
successes
regarding patients with lung cancer
prostate colon
glioblastoma lymphoma just to name a few
i do change everybody's diet so it's not
just cannabis medicine but this is
who i am i'm an anesthesiologist by
training not an
oncologist and so when patients come to
me with
um without any other options i want to
make sure that they have the best that
they can be
but my passion now and my uh conviction
for the majority of my time
is that we are currently through pure
green pharmaceuticals running
clinical trials that are irb approved
that are listed on clinicaltrials.gov
and we are seeing tremendous successes
we do understand that these types of
trials are not for the faint of heart i
mean it's not easy to do these things
but the interesting thing about the
owner of of
pure green is i think he subscribes to
this his name is stephen
goldner and he made he uh was the person
that created the liquid form of
methadone and now he is
committed to creating a pharmaceutical
company based on cannabis medicine
children pharmaceuticals that we are
limited by the imaginations of ourselves
and the burdens
of others so we're hoping to overcome
those burdens with our own imaginations
and with all pharmaceuticals there
really does need to be a balance between
safety and efficacy anytime we extract
um an active pharmaceutical ingredient
from its original source there's always
up and down stream effects
so if you look at the willow work that
where
um so this salicyline is that is made
that is used a chemical used to make
aspirin a very big difference between
the effects of aspirin and the effects
of
the chemical from the willow bark
cannabis thus far though has shown a
tremendous safety profile whether
it's a single molecule or in combination
there are people that say and we all
agree of the entourage effect there's
the synergistic effect of all the camp
of all the cannabis chemicals
so the question is we have an idea
we have to figure out a way to execute
we actually have to execute and then we
have to collate the results
and share it and so the question is
research
is it worth it and in my opinion
i think yes now this was supposed to be
my last slide
but in order to um sort of acknowledge
what's going on
you know globally with this covid19
virus
pilgrim pharmaceuticals has
thought about innovative ways of
continuing to push
the body of knowledge forward by
introducing remote patient recruitment
as well as
running our entire clinical trial
non-fda clinical trials remotely through
a smartphone app
and recruiting patients using social
media
and i would like to offer anyone in
michigan who has osteoarthritis of the
knee pain
if they're interested in participating
in a clinical trial in pure green
please email me and we'll talk about it
and if anyone has
any other medical condition in michigan
that would be interested
in future programs i would like to offer
my email as well
we're looking at ptsd we're looking at
diabetic pain
we're looking at insomnia anxiety
and so please feel free to send me an
email
um we'll put you on the list so that as
our programs roll out
we can contact you and again i want to
thank you for listening
and i would like to thank lab roots for
allowing me this platform
to talk a little bit about clinical
trials um
what they are the difficulties the
challenges the successes
and why they're they're worth the effort
and thank you
and be safe
thank you dr kimlis for the outstanding
presentation for additional informative
presentations
view our agenda on our events page and
as a final reminder
our speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
thank you again for your participation